it's time for my angle part 2a OCS
climate change con I have some bad news
for you
AOC has insomnia and she thinks this one
thing should keep you up - even while I
was on vacation I woke up in the middle
of the night 3:30 in the morning just
about climate change Lakers are melting
our sea levels are rising I have a
question
does that box mac and cheese she was
making come with a tinfoil hat
well like Bernie with his comments about
the Chinese Mayo sees late-night musings
revealed the true agenda of the climate
change crew this is not about like just
putting solar panels on people's roofs
this is about changing our consumption
this is about living our whole lives in
a way that is more sustainable and
humane we're not trying to end cows and
plane travel but we need to change our
lives
there you have it as I told you in part
one of my angle
this isn't about science it's not about
facts this is really about government
controlling almost every aspect of your
life but the liberal elites won't change
their lifestyles under this system they
won't change their lifestyles one iota
as in any socialist state there's the
very rich their way at the top and their
Stooges in government who dictate the
terms for everybody else then there's a
puny beleaguered middle class and the
rest are the poor people Leonardo
DiCaprio he's still gonna fly to movie
shoots and social media conferences on a
g5 you think overhauling our economy to
decarbonize
and save the planet is gonna be
expensive try not decarbonizing our
economy and allowing sea levels to rise
every coastal city to go underwater
every Midwestern city experiencing
drought on a level that we have not seen
that's gonna be way more expensive
that means the Obamas are gonna be way
out of their house and Martha's been
here too Wow
so don't sweat the 93 trillion dollar
price tag for the green New Deal
it'll practically pay for itself now
won't we heard that before and that's
the angle part too